more news here at six o'clock Nathan
chasing horse remains in custody here in
Las Vegas while Canada meantime is
beefing up its charges against him the
Dances with Wolves actor now facing more
allegations of sexual abuse 8 news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy has been
uncovering new information since January
six months later here's the update
Nathan chasing horses accused of
victimizing indigenous underage girls
and women for at least two decades the
latest charges against the Dances with
Wolves actor from suchina Nation police
in Canada near Calgary we had a lot of
collaboration with our Las Vegas
Partners in relation to
some of the evidence that was brought
forward and there is no question that he
is guilty of those the latest warrants
for nine counts including sexual assault
sexual exploitation and two other counts
related to minors Sergeant Nancy farmer
says chasing horse used his position as
a self-proclaimed Medicine Man to abuse
those who trusted him we need to support
our victims as they come forward in
speaking their truth in some of these
offenses have happened so many years ago
chasing horse was arrested at his North
Las Vegas home where he lived with
several wives in January he's charged
with 18 counts related to the alleged
sexual abuse of two women one of them
while she was underage he also now faces
federal charges in the U.S and previous
warrants in Montana and Canada after
additional women spoke up and after some
investigations were reopened had any of
these alleged victims previously come
forward before January in 2005 it was
investigated as time the evidence that
we had did not meet the threshold for a
charge and with the additional
information that we were able to gather
we were able to lay charges chasing
horses asking the Nevada Supreme Court
to drop the charges against him here in
Clark County no decision has been made
yet it's unclear whether he'd be
extradited to Canada in the meantime he
remains in custody here in Las Vegas
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now